tonight we get a firsthand account of
how difficult it is to get in and out of
afghanistan my colleague bret baier
talked with republican congressman mark
wayne mullen earlier today
mullen is back from his trip to the
region which he says he paid for himself
and with the help of private
contributions
mike thank you joining us now republican
congressman mark wayne mullen from
oklahoma i just had an interesting trip
overseas got a lot of attention thanks
for being here thank you for having me
let's start at the beginning right how
does this start
well i want to make it very clear i
wasn't looking
to try to get into afghanistan that
wasn't what this thing started out to be
uh what started was people started
calling me one help
and
we had been getting
friends of mine that was in the service
that said can you help our interpreter
get out uh which we had a lot of
conversations about that then we started
getting phone calls from people that had
family members or friends that were
amsets or americans american citizens
amsets for short to get to get them out
and i said let me make a phone call and
it came out that they needed a state
department or a government
entity to sponsor their flight going in
that's the only way they could get in
and no one would sponsor their fight
even though it was
designated to get these 20
americans out
and so they called me back and said
would you be interested in sponsoring
the flight
and i said i mean what do you mean
financially and they said no
uh congress a congressman can sponsor a
flight going in and it gives one of
these other departments cover because
it's kind of no one wants to touch it
because i i personally believe
right it was because they knew this was
a hot mess and so that's we that's how
this thing whole thing started so you
don't actually get into afghanistan to
get people out as this thing moved
forward
is they wanted
everybody kept denying them and then
they asked would you go with us
and these are tier one operators these
are delta guys um special forces
these guys are are legit i'm i'm nobody
i'm i'm just a congressman are you from
oklahoma you're a businessman it's your
mixed martial arts background but no
military right that doesn't know that
that doesn't play it well in this i
wasn't trying to go over there and be a
cowboy or anything like that it was just
what else you do when you see a problem
how do you say no if you can be an asset
and they left they believed i could be
an asset uh we got a human humanitarian
um a fight plan from uh faa
and everything was good to go we left um
we left the united states we had a time
of arrival at hakaiah inc in the kabul
hakai is the airport there in kabul
and we got there and we're drawing an
approach and they canceled our ppr and
uh and so we circled the airport
probably for an hour and we had five
pprs cancelled every time they'd cancel
the agency that would that was trying to
get us in would give us a new one they
actually went into the tower to say let
them land we were on the phone with them
texting we couldn't talk we were texting
back and forth and they kept issuing us
new ones
and they would never let us in
afghanistan and i'll tell you this too
unfortunately one of our american
citizens her two-year-old son
and i believe it was her father to which
i all have passports on
we lost contact of because they were at
the abbey gate and a few hours later the
abbey gate blew up
and we haven't had we haven't had any
contact with them since and i believe
it's because they were caught up in that
um and and so what they did by playing
politics on this for whatever reason so
you don't know who shuts you down from
landing i don't know what what i don't
know who shut us down but i think it was
100 directed from the state department
at some point you go on to tajikistan no
i never went to tajikistan didn't go in
no that is absolutely
absolutely false um we we did work
around the region but tachica stand
was um unfortunately the ambassador far
machine was not helpful at all
and a lot of misinformation was is going
out about that and for the storyline
that said that you possibly
interrupted some covert thing that was
going on or some operation in tajikistan
no i don't
i i don't have a clue what they're
talking about
this is what the ambassador premachine
told me he says it's very sensitive
right now marquins very sensitive
because putin and chinese and the
chinese chinese governments come to be
here september 5th it's very sensitive
i said i get it's very sensitive i don't
need any of your assets i don't need
anything i i'm first of all is making
you aware that we're coming in
but i also and i also made the point i
said but we are coming in with a large
sum of cash why are you coming with a
large sum of cash
sir you you do know that we got to go
through 16 checkpoints just to get from
kabul to mez each one of those charge
someone to come through
i i i don't know what the requirements
are what are the requirements to bring
in this cash
and he says i can't assist you i can't
help you why
i was told not to
you were told not to help an american
citizen you were told by the federal
government
in washington dc
not to help when we're not trying to
smuggle anybody over
we're trying to do a job that president
biden wouldn't do you know a lot of
people look at what you're trying to do
as admirable you had house minority
leader kevin mccarthy saying he really
didn't want
members
doing this on their own because
one they could become hostages two they
could become
uh problems that the military would have
to deal with sure do you think about
that whether that was
worth it i did
but how do you say no
i mean how do you say no when you have
the opportunity to do something believe
me my wife wasn't happy about me going
yeah i'm sure um my kids wouldn't happen
about me going and be quite frank with
you
all of us that was on that plane we felt
like we probably had a 50-50 chance of
coming back why should we not think that
this was you know bravado or
testosterone or an effort to get the
spotlight i understand that like how do
you respond to that well i i'm not
rainbow yeah i never pretended to be
rainbow um
we were surrounded by great people of
all the guys that i was working with i'm
the low man on the totem pole and i
understood that
but they felt like i could beat
assistance to them how
logistically maybe opened the doors for
them making phone calls
and
and being able to take in the sivs or
the amp sets as they came onto the plane
and and that was the plan that plan
changed and and it changed when we
wasn't allowed to get into afghanistan
we quickly realized that
the the the the president and the state
department general milley general
mckenzie were lying to the to the
american people by saying everybody
wanted out could get out that's that's a
lie that is a bold face 100 live because
we're working with these individuals and
you know today that there are just a
bunch of them still stuck there right
now as we speak
right before we we we started talking i
called the guys that are still over
there and they said there was five
planes setting at uh mez meza sharif
with um amsets sivs and refugees on it
and american citizens
uh special immigration
visas and refugees and they may be p1
p2s which are levels of refugees to that
we can get out
but they can't get clearance to get out
because no country is willing to help
when we called the state department
about this the state department said
we're not in control the airspace we're
not handling any of that well it's our
mess i don't care which way you think
about it it's our mess the united states
created this vacuum to allow the taliban
to come in the the president biden in
his horrific withdrawal has caused this
to happen do you have any regrets about
what you did absolutely not i do it
again tomorrow
i we we were saving people's lives what
did 535 members decide to you know get
on a plane and go everybody's helping
right now i don't care if you're
republican or democrat everybody's
helping i've heard from a lot of
different members that are trying to do
their their thing everybody has a
different way of helping do you know why
all those other governments were going
out and picking up their individuals and
bringing them back in because there was
three taliban checkpoints before you
could get to hakaya and all three of
them would could charge you a tax and
the tax was anywhere between 500 to 4
thousand dollars this one young lady and
her four kids to which i have recordings
of we were recording as we were walking
through because i was on the phone with
the state department for 12 hours trying
to get someone from the state department
to come out of the gate to get her for
12 hours
12 hours i have it recorded
couldn't get anybody to come out she had
to come through that cost her two
thousand dollars they kept the state
department kept saying hey go up and
talk to them tell them they're waiting
on us tell them give me your name they
know you're coming
five times she approaches this guard
with the taliban
the last time they stuck a pistol to her
head with her kids there i have it
recorded with her kids screaming and
crying
she goes back and she
she's crying so hard that she begins to
puke the mother did and the state
department center up there five times
saying we've got clearance for and here
here we are the united states government
and we're negotiating with the taliban
to get american citizens out and then
the president united states is going to
go to the mike and say that every
american that wanted out got out
i have a list of 50 that won out that
they haven't got out i have a list of 50
that we've ran out of kabul and put in
safe houses around afghanistan that i
promise you
they want it out you think we're going
to get these people out
we're going to get some
but there's going to be some that's
going to die because of the failure from
president biden
i promise you that
at some point they're going to lose
patience and aren't going to keep
letting us drive past these checkpoints
and paying them off sorry taxes
you know that's what they call a tax
and and when i say that blood is on his
hands
that means the president biden's hands i
mean that with everything in my heart
it's his fault
i wouldn't have been over there i
wouldn't even thought about going if it
wasn't for his failure i wouldn't have
put i wouldn't put my life in danger i
wouldn't have put my kids and my wife
through that i wouldn't have put anybody
through it and you'd do it again
without even hesitation well congressman
we appreciate your time i know you just
traveled back and
stories compelling thank you sir